catch tony's twitch stream the [ __ ] list
roundup at twitch.tv slash the tony
michaels
we're back to the king of brilliant this
is the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
we want to talk about gas prices some
more but really we we want to get some
expert advice on messaging
so we we we bring in the great rachel
bitkoffer from strike pack uh she's all
over messaging all the time we know you
guys love rachel here rachel how are you
we appreciate you coming on
dude i'm honored to be here on this very
big day tony yes it is a big day we are
announcing that we we're now under the
minus touch minus media network umbrella
so that's very exciting that's very
couldn't happen to a more deserving duo
than the two of you guys absolutely
and i'm very snobby i won't watch most
things as you know so well
everyone here hi rachel they're they're
saying hi
um everyone everyone loves rachel it's
the party it is it is
of parties uh what's with what's with
the party of of not knowing what gas
prices are and how gas prices work how
do we message this because i think i
think a lot of a lot of people out there
that are pro-democracy
are struggling like because it is so
simple to say oh joe biden he's
he's making the gas presses high and and
these morons just believe this stuff uh
willy-nilly what what is what is part of
that messaging how can we make sure that
our neighbors our community members and
just morons out there on the internet on
social media understand that the
president united states doesn't have a
gasoline button that's not that's not
how it works
i mean technically he's got a small
gasoline button but yeah it's exactly
right so here let's let's just kind of
contextualize this for people
um you know gas prices were in were kind
of pressured upwards uh you guys were
talking about keystone xl the reason
keystone xl got tanked even though trump
approved it unilaterally was because the
market didn't require it right uh when
gas prices are stable it does not work
out anymore because of natural gas
investment and other
alternative fuels eco fuels to build
something like keystone especially given
the contentious that goes with it so not
only would it not fix the problem now it
would never fix the problem and that's
why the oil and gas lobby or company
that wanted to build it gave up
um and in addition to that as you're
noting we're coming out of the season
where they've been blaming biden for gas
and inflation and it was a huge part of
their reelection strategy and i really
do want to underscore like one thing
about joe biden i mean if you ever had
any doubts about him in terms of party
over country this should answer it
because what he's done today by
blockading russian oil which is actually
a fairly small export for us
is going to drive these prices higher
and in some places they're seven dollars
in california right in l.a so um you
know he's he's literally working against
his own political self-interest to work
for the country's national security
interest right and and that was a good
serve up because there's two messages i
think that that people should start
pounding and i'll certainly try to
create some stuff to help along with
this and that is number one getting
people to understand it's putin's tax
gas tax right what we call it every
[ __ ] time you say the word gas okay
so i'm trying to teach people every time
you say the word corporation gotta add
republican party because people don't
make those connections so you wanna
when they're hitting biden attacks biden
gas violence whatever you want to be
hitting back with putin and then that
gives you the moral leverage too by the
way if they if i mean if they're i would
assume they're in a shamelessly pursue
this line of attack no matter what it
does to you know the
nato or the international situations
that we're facing
uh that way if if they continue to do
that then when we get to the fall
we'll be able to position them as the
anti-america party right well you know i
just had a
fantastic idea and you know these ideas
happen live on air so you know i i
noticed these these mornings
i'm taking shits and i'm sorry well
i get all
i get a lot of good ideas when i'm
taking this [ __ ] too what people out
there don't know is a lot of times my
best tweets happen while i'm on the
commode for sure
from the community
i tweet from the commode all the time
all the time one of my most favorite
tweets that i have is about michael
flynn and i say i just took a huge [ __ ]
it smelled like a traitor i named it
michael flynn you are the last rush
limbaugh
i know i know i know so so here's here's
here's my idea because i've seen these
morons post pictures of the gas pump
with the price and then it has a sticker
of biting
oh yeah you know what we could do yeah
rachel i would be i would be willing i
would be willing to partner and make a
make a putin sticker that says i did
that
with the putin sticker i love it yeah
let's [ __ ] do it dude let's do it
happen right that's right that's right
this is how it works this is how the
ideas flow that's how the ideas feel i
want to go to putin though and why why
this is so important that american the
american people understand what this
sacrifice means not just not just for
like your pocketbook but what it
actually means geopolitically and really
honestly you called them the traitor
party and it's not just their party it
is also their media let me bring up um
mr tucker carlson here um
last night this was this is his
his explanation of what yeah right of
why
why
putin wants ukraine which is a little
twisted but let's listen then we'll talk
about it now it's obvious vladimir putin
just invaded ukraine because he didn't
want ukraine to join nato putin
certainly had other motives as well
people always do have multiple motives
but that's the main reason russia
invaded the russians don't want american
missiles on their border they don't want
a hostile government next door
now that's true whether you're allowed
to say it in public right now or not it
has been true for a long time a lot has
been written about this over many years
by serious people no one who knows
anything and is honest will tell you
putin invaded ukraine simply because he
is evil okay so here's the thing wait no
wait there's an important part play that
will let the end of
putin may be evil he certainly seems to
be but he also has strategic motives in
doing that whether or not you agree with
those motivations that's irrelevant
because what he just said there
was
he's been flip-flopping this whole thing
uh does putin eat your dog does putin do
this
sorry not your dog does putin eat dogs
you ate dogs just dogs just dogs does
putin do uh is he yeah right
[Laughter]
say you're a racist did putin try to get
fired all this stuff right
and then he was like oh putin will
clearly is responsible for this and then
last week said something that was
pro-putin and then now he's like putin
is evil it would seem that he is so it's
like
which
which one is it man like we know we
actually know what it is but we're
trying to determine that right because
here's the thing tony and gabe both and
the audience too to understand the
republican base the people out there and
this includes right-winging independence
are not going to rally around the flag
rally around america versus russia and
the west versus this russian conflict
unless a republican opinion elite elites
like tucker carlson give them permission
to right so one of the first things when
this whole thing started i started to do
was really train full [ __ ] fire on me
on shaming republicans as much as
possible on this issue of national
security and it's not just for fun okay
i mean it is kind of fun but mostly
we have fun doing it here
but honest to [ __ ] pete there's
always a method to my madness okay and
like the reason i'm focusing on that so
heavily is that if we do not keep at
least the chunk that we have now of the
republican coalition on the proved
democracy in the in this western context
side then we're going to be up shit's
creek in terms of national security and
it's much i mean it's as dangerous as
the domestic stuff
um with this party so we really i'm you
know pushing the elites because those
are the people that are going to give
the permission structure if you saw if
you did if you saw what were normal
things would happen in this kind of
situation where all of the republican
party was rallying around anti-russia i
mean it's the easiest [ __ ] thing for
them to do is hate russia it used to be
anyway um then what you would see is
biden at 80 on approval okay and you're
never gonna see that with tucker carlson
working for putin
well you know that's that's the craziest
part because you know they they claim
they love ronald reagan and all that but
they forget like he stood and said mr
gorbachev tear down this wall and we are
back to the moment where they're
cheering
not only for a wall here but they're
cheering for a wall in ukraine because
tucker's argument here is that putin
went because of nato he didn't want nato
forces on his border but if he takes
ukraine poland
is on the border and there's the nato
forces there this this because
because the and i say this all the time
dum-dums do dumb things
and it's not because people aren't
intelligent and they can't look at a map
and find ukraine and figure out oh okay
here's nato forces here but they won't
dum-dums do dumb things and tucker
carlson knows
dumb dumbs do dumb things so he can say
things like oh this is all all because
of nato and it's nothing to do with that
that's all [ __ ] that's all bs and
and really go ahead yeah well let's
think about what their solution his work
around is right here his workaround is
to um
tell people you know all right
how do i explain this all right his work
around is then to go [ __ ] on nato right
exactly okay so like oh no i'm not
anti-american i'm just anti-america's
world order and geopolitical dominance
by a native because nato's not a goddamn
charity organization that's what donald
trump never [ __ ] understood nato is
about us okay and it helps the world but
ultimately it helps us and um you know
it really is just astounding uh i i
don't think there's a conservative
movement i mean in in the uk or some
other country it would be this like very
small fringe minority of a third party
right or you're not going to see tories
running around which who are um you know
equivalently conservative not as radical
obviously because we're played with this
radicalism but they're conservative
people and they aren't sitting there
talking about how shitty it is that we
pressured putin into invading ukraine
it's all our [ __ ] fault because of
nato
yeah that's pretty it's pretty crazy to
see the things that people say online
were like oh you know if you
uh you know it should be very like clear
control like you should not be
supporting what putin does
but if you support in any way or
of ukraine or go against putin
then there is this uh knee-jerk response
that is regurgitated by people where
they say like well oh okay like
imperialism huh like like that's the
that's what you wanna
like one that's not it but also you
wanna fight and and make it about that
when it's not about that at all right
like you've got a guy who's the fascist
dictator trying to take over a land that
he
feels like is privileged to having and
you say hey
as a human you shouldn't be murdering
other humans to take that land right and
they're like okay all right so now
you're pro-nato okay imperialist and
it's like what do you think is happening
right now what are you witnessing that
you're willing to ignore right
well i mean i mean this is this is what
they do this projection um i mean here
look here the the the freedom convoy
people are are are protesting for
freedom against mandates that don't
exist and now they're going to protest
gas prices uh while they drive their big
huge trucks and spend needlessly gas
which takes up more supply which in
essence raises prices but here is a
here's a video from russia from st
petersburg of how people are having to
protest the war there right now because
they can't say war anymore they passed
the law you can't say war but here's how
they're protesting this is freedom in
russia
this is it right here this they just can
walk that is all they can do they can't
say anything they can't dissident on
their cell phones um they're checking
their cell phones yeah to make sure
they're not dissidents
a bunch of truckers complaining about
wearing a mask and getting a vaccine and
that's the tyrannical government they're
the people that kept me in my home for
two years and it's like no one kept you
in your home okay there was a national
health care emergency that we had to
deal with and we took preventative
measures no one was forcing you to do
anything also these private businesses
made their own private decisions to say
hey you have to wear a mask to get a
vaccine whatever yeah no [ __ ] dave i
mean here's the thing like they had to
they in other countries where they
didn't just let it rip and kill a
million people okay because most western
democracies didn't do that
here we did and that's because people
could go outside in other countries
their quarantines were enforced okay if
you had to be headed to her for a work
to leave your house and even then it was
you know you had you you could get
stopped on the street and asked to
produce proof that you should be out we
didn't quarantine like that uh nothing
like that it ever happened in america
not even in the bluest places so these
whiny little [ __ ] with their little
truck protest i was so i'm so glad that
you know we're watching women deposit
their young children into strangers arms
on trains and then turning around to
pick up rifles to sit side by side with
their husbands to try to defend their
fleeting democracy because ukrainians
don't know better than almost any
[ __ ] buddy in the west right it's
better to live free
or die die fighting than live on your
knees right you know i i i think we read
each other's minds we are always on the
same page look at the video that i had
queued up here let me play this this is
of ukrainian women now this isn't
cosplay for for lauren beaubert uh
marjorie taylor green or thomas matthew
massey you bunch of cosplay [ __ ] this
is real [ __ ] these women are gonna go
actually fight
in war to defend their country not give
some [ __ ] some sort of cosplay for a
christmas card here's the real thing
of lady there tony thanks that's right
that's uh very intimidating and
something again like you mentioned
lauren but like you would never see
lauren bobert
or anyone of the republican party
actually
pick up arms and go defend their country
instead they'll put a bazooka on their
back and walk into a subway and order a
12-inch you know sandwich right like
these are people who are like oh my
freedoms and it's like no one is taking
them away
so shut the [ __ ] up like that at the end
like no one no one is no one is
searching your phone on the street and
searching and going through social media
to say that anything was anti-russia and
then say oh you know what we're gonna
boot you away and put you in jail or
make you serve in our military no one's
doing that that is actually the the
tyrannical government that you are
afraid of that [ __ ] never happened in
the u.s our government is so
anti-tyrannical and this is going to be
my last i have to hard exit right now
but this is this our government is so
anti-tyrannical
that when you try to
you know plot a coup
a seizure of power and a legal seizure
of power that
culminates in a in an armed attack
on the nation's capital even then like
it takes a year
to like the wheels of justice to begin
to even turn right like that's freedom
[ __ ] i gotta go
thanks rachel we appreciate you joining
us come back anytime we'll see you next
week have a good one putin stickers
putin stickers i'll be i'll be in we're
on it next week you guys are there guys
better keep following us
let's do the putin stickers thanks
rachel